continuing our look at the race for
Clark County Commission today we're
focusing on District F and the incumbent
is commissioner Justin Jones
commissioner Jones good to see you sir
good to see you too all right so we're
going to talk about some of the issues
of the campaign and some of the issues
in the district in a moment but first I
want to talk about some issues uh
happening in the news right now a couple
of things I actually spoke with your
colleague commissioner segrovement about
a couple of weeks ago public
administrator Rob tell us now accused of
murder as we know what did you as
commissioner know
leading up to this alleged murder what
did Commissioners know about the
allegations of and the concerns from
people in Mr telus's office ahead of
time well but I would say before the
primary election there were some
concerns that were raised at the time
it's always challenging when they're
coming really from a political opponent
within the office it's a little bit
harder to judge what the what the
motivations are so we are aware with the
review journal story and some of the
other allegations that came up there and
that's why we had Mike Murphy who was
our formerly with Clark County come in
to the office and really take over
running the operations to make sure that
the employees in that office felt like
they were they were being treated fairly
and there wasn't political games going
on why didn't Commissioners do more
there have been some suggestions that
Commissioners while they yes appointed
Mr Murphy to and and heard the concerns
there wasn't enough of an aggressive or
intentional response to try and really
do something about this well I think
it's easy to hindsight's 2020 when
there's a murder involved right I don't
think that under the circumstances at
the time
there was enough information Beyond some
some complaints we addressed those
complaints unfortunately obviously for
for a reporter that led to a murder
which which is obviously tragic and and
and certainly not in line with what was
expected and when you say address the
concern are you talking about appointing
Mike Murphy to to the uh to the office
yes I think that that that was the the
whole point Mike Mike was with the
county for for decades and was very well
respected in the community final
question on this uh commissioner secret
Bloom suggested removing the public
administrator's office and some of the
other sort of downed ballot offices
removing them from the ballot uh do you
support that idea I think that that's
something we should look at I don't know
that there's any particular reason why
the voters should be able to to decide
some of these down ballot races that
really aren't political in the first
place so I think that's something that
certainly the legislature will will take
a look at
all right so uh let's get to the
campaign itself here you're running for
re-election what does District F your
District need that hasn't been achieved
in the last four years well you know
it's been an interesting four years John
uh we had a lot of goals for district F
and for the county more generally and
then covid hit us and so we had to
really focus all of our attention on
making sure that we protected People's
Health and well-being and did everything
we could in order to re re invigorate
the economy and so that's what we did we
spent a lot of time and effort on covid
and you've seen the economy come roaring
back we we spend a lot of time and
effort and and frankly money in
supporting small business owners who
were really struggling through the
pandemic but also coming out of the
pandemic to make sure that they were
able to keep their doors open and expand
their operations
um your critican your opponent I should
say in this race has criticized and
others have as well not just your votes
but the votes of the entire commission
with regards to the coronavirus
restrictions the mandates shutting down
the strip the effects on small business
and then subsequently the money that is
poured in and has been allocated by the
county and elsewhere
has the money gone to the right place
to help these small businesses yeah
absolutely I think that that it's proven
that for the small business owners
certainly in my district and across the
county this has kept them kept them able
to to have their doors open or to reopen
their doors after the pandemic and so I
think definitely the money went to the
right place and is continuing to to help
them we've got our small business grant
program that's going to get back up and
running now for those that want to
expand their operations we know
everyone's struggling to hire right now
and so we want to make sure that there
are opportunities for these small
business owners to create new jobs for
for people here in southern Nevada your
opponent also suggests that broadly in
Clark County there's a lot of money
being wasted there isn't enough of
watching of the money being spent
keeping an eye on where the taxpayers
money is going are you confident that
the contracts that are signed this is
kind of a broad question I realized but
do you think that the taxpayers are
being well served by you and the other
commissioner owners with their money I
think absolutely our CFO is one of the
frankly most conservative CFOs out there
pre-pandemic we were in the strongest
financial situation of any local
jurisdiction and we continue to be so
there's a reason why our bond ratings
are at the top of every jurisdiction in
the state of Nevada we are fiscally
conservative we make sure that we spend
every dollar in the right way and if any
issues come up we go audit those those
expenditures and we've clawed back money
when we found that there were issues out
there even from nonprofits one of uh an
issue that you have close to your heart
is the issue of Red Rock and protection
of Red Rock both uh as County
Commissioner and beforehand as well talk
about some of the efforts that you have
taken to try and protect Red Rock but
also increase access to it sure
absolutely um as as a lot of the viewers
might know there's been a big battle
between a developer and Clark County
over the last 20 years the original
proposal from the developer was for more
than 5 000 homes and the the County
Commission uh in 2019 had denied the
request from the developer to waive a
condition that related to the road the
developer finally after 20 years came in
with a proposal that was within the
density that was permitted up there when
he bought it and so that was the subject
of a recent vote on the County
Commission well it's also the subject of
litigation that you're involved in as
well your opponent is accusing you of
being corrupt there's allegations of
conflict of interest that you voted on
this even though before you were on the
commission your previous as an attorney
you were involved in this case
allegations of Records being deleted
public records being deleted how do you
respond to these accusations well sure I
think I've responded publicly to these
accusations before with regards to to
the vote and the allegations that I was
conflicted out that's why I firmatively
went to the Nevada Commission on ethics
laid everything out to them before that
a vote and they said that I was required
to disclose my prior affiliation with uh
with a non-profit say Red Rock but but
that I was not only allowed to vote but
that was my obligation on behalf of the
voters who elected me to participate in
those kinds of discussions is every
public record that comes came from your
office regarding this development with
the Mr Rhodes in that development is
every public record still accounted for
as far as I know okay
um let's move on to another aspect of
sort of broadly Clark County we were
talking before about business recovery
um what can be done in the next four
years if you're re-elected to try and
help get businesses back on their feet
because a lot of them are still
struggling and if you look at sort of
the the recovery of the economy in
southern Nevada there's no doubt there
is a recovery but it might be behind the
curve of a lot of other parts in the
country sure so I I sit on the Economic
Development Authority and uh as part of
the lvga we are really focusing on not
only bringing in new jobs into our
community here we've talked about
economic diversification in Nevada for
for decades now we don't ever seem to do
it when times are good we think great
the the strip is going to pay for
everything and I think for the first
time we're really focusing on not just
jobs but on jobs that matter in
manufacturing and technology and so we
are fostering those opportunities with
our with our director of community and
economic development at the county
something that we didn't have before and
that I'm very proud of having worked on
at the Clark County and as part of that
we're supporting those small business
owners we're expanding our Redevelopment
agency we're investing back into those
parts of the community that have really
faced challenges over the years and we
want to make sure that we Foster areas
like mine out in the out in the
southwest part of town where you'll see
our state bird the crane all over on on
the curve out there but we want to make
sure in in the older parts of town that
we're really investing in those areas
too so if you are re-elected
first County Commission meeting first a
day on the job in January 2023 what's
the first thing you really want to try
and Tackle well I think economic
development is is definitely top my
priority list affordable housing I think
we've already taken the the first
important steps in in funding a lot of
those priorities so I'll be focusing on
broadening our economic base bringing
new jobs to Nevada so that we can
continue the economic uptight here all
right commissioner Justin Jones running
for re-election in District F appreciate
the time sir thank you very much and
good luck thanks John